[Musica]
ciao family bentornati solite stress
oggi nuovo video 8 al giovane vado a
mettere in tantissimi ingredienti
dell'estremo ognuno di un tipo credo
fino a quanto dura lo slime ad ora e una
sala che fanno in america e in america
si chiamano vasquez line all
non so che la petrone italiano one dolci
star di un ingrediente dentro lo slime
ad esempio schiuma da barba
dodo metterne tantissimo e vedo fino a
quanto lo slime riesce a contenere la
schiuma da barba thomas bach e stia
capito o un bel po di ingredienti ma non
vedo l'ora di fare questa prova
mi raccomando un bel life come sempre a
10.000 lifeline marco un'altra challenge
scrivete nei commenti che eviti volete
vedere e accurate un po cosa preso
quella bestemmia è ovviamente per lisa
finta che compra bellissime reti sotto
mio dio è una bellezza età finta rota
oggi è troppo bella su questo da primark
cosa non cadete pronti porta fine pop
corn iniziano subito ora dobbiamo
iniziare con il model
avete presente raiola 12
questo gioco è nato quindi praticamente
andiamo prima fare lo stop
sentivo contest è grande ha detto
comunque notare questo contenitore di
scola che sembra tipo uno di quei
contenitori grandi perché i tempi che si
contino questi sono cinque litri
quindi quello che la dinamica in genere
non c'era fin su amazon a loro questo
questo e mi ha detto che l'inter mi
sembra però la forte con quel grande
perché mi ha incarnato la squadra suppo
e piccolo ho detto vabbè andiamo ad
attivarlo e propri mezzi
mi chiedo come si tenta polveri green
corno e soluzione a tale tipo kay vado a
mettere una goccia basta del bloom e
così fanno celeste provate a indovinare
se uscirà fosse toglie o non s quindi
questo primo online con l'ammonimento
play provata indovinare se uscirà forse
non c'era scrivete l'ora nei commenti
queste che per correttezza
e anche un po così pronto
ok ragazzi stiamo quasi sentite qua ho
tra l'altro il sito super glossy
cappello d'oro questo colore carenza è
troppo che ci colgono mischiano ancora
un pochino meglio truccate che bel
colore è fighissimo
mi sembra la stessa che in genere è vero
quello che uso in genere la scuola si
chiama favola qui stiamo anche quella
che vengano o la scuola vuol sentire
questa sera cleopatre bianca quindi era
stato il cappellano l'avevo mai provata
[Musica]
mi sembra un po più grossi però io mi
sembra un pò più liquida come un corposo
lo slang è pronto ora andiamo ad
aggiungere il leccese pronti a vedere
come diventa allora una busta intera 226
g quindi vediamo prima se riesce a
contenerlo
so che bravi per date non c'è grande
tanto che siete pronti abbiamo mischiato
a prendiamo un po mi piace i suoni che
fa finora non sembra male verrebbe che
bello il colore però per gli effetti
bianchi sembra una nuvola bis ma devo
dire che mi sta piacendo finora sembra
superbello guardate sta uscendo
bellissimo ragazzo non ci posso credere
sono state di ha messo così top play
bellissimo fantastico
e anche morbido v che figo sempre più
morbido pelo mischio più diventa più
morbido quindi devo dire che questo
esperimento qua è resistito molto bene
mi piace un sacco però di non macchiarmi
le mani come sempre mettiamo sembra un
po un pack the r's lime e soffice e
ragazzi che molto dati al primo
esperimento così tanta klein slime
glieli do 9 e mezzo perché mi piace
davvero tantissimo e ora passiamo al
prossimo ingrediente di cui andremo a
metterne tantissimo e cioè passiamo alla
schiuma da barba
facciamo la forma sembra un floppy
gigantesco trendissimo segnano
esperimento con la schiuma da barba
quindi prima di montare lo slime e
indovinate quali sono i miei unici
coloranti a disposizione il blu che ho
già notato e l'altro il verde ovviamente
perché non lo uso mai non parlando con
di tale che se uniamo il ruolo verdetto
per vestire bene acqua tutto giallo
giallo non penso proprio che sia quindi
proviamo verde acqua ride
allora
anche così le due di verde 4 lo vediamo
che cosa mi raccomando fate il tifo per
oppure sono solo uno diverso e 5 anzi no
dai primi 21 fi2 fi 22 di verde e 42
indovinate nei commenti che cono
riuscita vediamo chi indovina e 5 di blu
4 depurato 123 a
il blick prevale vediamo anche il verde
è in effetti forse è un po verde acqua
va bene dai
tutto ciò che mangia parma che diamo
quarta sesta
[Musica]
la torre di più
nel frattempo il coso per mischiare
stato sotterrato sotto la firma da barba
forse è meglio cominciare a girare ma
prima la mette tutta aiuto su giacche
per ogni tanto che con slide wow
cervello per l'aggressione così però
fighissimi accadendo
no no non carriere ma dopotutto carla
vabbè a niente aspetta che sta finendo
forse resterà in mezz ora sappiamo
quando la palla ce l'abbiamo fatta
secondo voi riuscirà lo slang questa
volta non uscirono scrivete nei commenti
pronti ma perdono il cosa con dentro il
con la spatola e strano pratica sto
facendo ma che si sentono questo l con
la schiuma da barba sta passando la
schiuma da barba canuta non si modella
bene perché sto facendo una parte di
sopra della torta lighting è tolta la
banda fini è possibile mi chiama troppo
pieno
oddio come sempre come sempre dovrò
pulire un casino bestiale come sempre
lasciate un like di supporto per tutte
le volte che devo pulire dappertutto no
strabordando sotto wall cromatiche figo
che
bellissimo
non so nemmeno se si sta mischiando con
la parte del socio
secondo me stesso governo la schiuma no
no cioè fosse resistenza devo cercare di
prenderlo da sotto
oddio no vabbè come faccio male no mi sa
che l'unica soluzione è david obey
talento permettere l'antipasto è tutto
se ti prendi ragazzi sono due modi o mio
dio no vabbè stranamente la sensazione
bella nelle vacua sembra panna riuscirò
ad attivarlo pancia chelsea che spiato
bene per niente
ok ok ora il mio assistente mi aiuta
cameraman e assistente
proviamo ad attivarlo di polvere mi
ricordano ai piedi del tappetino quel po
po davvero se succederà burton
se si attiverà ora qualcosa sta
succedendo soluzione per letti
non ci credo si sta soffermando
nonostante tutta la palma
non so se uscirà molto bene però
obiettivo la cosa che davvero era detto
nonostante tutta la panna con queste
cose perché poi ogni volta meglio
scrivono nei commenti guardate è la cosa
più che abbia mai toccato
no è fantastico dopo te lo faccio
toccare anche a dire novo del fantastico
non so come descrivere ricordo il suo
afoso facetime inventato un nuovo tipo
di slime due frame strabordante che
sulla foto come parla con la panna
la rassegna credo di inglobarlo bene
chiquita oddio no è fantastico fare
questi esperimenti a chiamiamo gli
esperimenti vieni tas giovane in cui
facciamo vari esperimenti non solo
quindi sly non manca è una cosa magari
scrivetemi nei commenti che esprime
mi consigliate di fare dopo
ma con già diventato grande
prima con era un po che è diventato
ciconte beh guardate non ho mai fatto né
mai toccato uno stand del genere è
incredibile è talmente profondo che è
tipo scicli
guardate sempre di giocare una nuvola è
bellissimo
le dimensioni sono praticamente di una
nuvola sito abbastanza che non mi potevo
so neanche dove metterlo per un
aspettavo veramente che uscisse davvero
è bellissimo ora vi faccio un po di
suoni smr
[Applauso]
ok ragazzi io mi sono innamorata di
questo nuovo tipo di slime che ho
scoperto non so se l'ha mai fatto
qualcun altro ma veramente è pazzesco
il nostro premio mineros line nuvola
perché sembra veramente una nuvola e tra
un lavoro incredibile e non c'è bisogno
di troppa colla per fare appunto cosa
strand gigante perché il signore per il
coincident simbolo di sacco di folla per
questo non c'è bisogno non ho veramente
che volevi da una dieta è fantastico una
nuvola
vorrei che potete toccarlo perché ed i
giovani dentro super luminoso o che ora
insieme dismetria toccarlo ma è
possibile veramente troppo bello
e adesso andiamo fare il terzo
esperimento terzo esperimento andiamo
pare rus live con tantissima neve quindi
devo ammettere veramente tantissimo
allora per farlo dobbiamo prima che
questa volta vado domenica mette il
colore blu scusate davvero ma i
coloranti che stanno arrivando non sono
ancora arrivati quindi questa volta ne
metto un bel po perché tanto
quindi può essere blu mescoliamo colore
primo ok ora possiamo andare ad atti
parlo di già polvere che ritorno allora
per l'ultima in bisogna o per attivarlo
opera in inglese
bisogna attivare un pochino di più
perché poi la neve fa scioglierlo
pochino quindi va attivato leggermente
di più
e strano come diversa questa colla è
notato anche tu come si attiva in modo
diverso di ancora chiaro con un po che
rimane così liquida questa colla almeno
fate inventori wow
ok
ecco fatto il nostro sud i'm base è
pronto allora non vado appoggiare qua
per il momento siamo a fare la nostra
neve finta allora non so se sapete ciò
sicuramente sì perché voi siete degli
esperti comunque per quello sono snai un
la quantità di neve e poca poca perché
voi aggiungendo l'acqua si moltiplica
tipo 100 volte il tuo tantissimo io
questa cosa aveva da mettere un sacco
proprio con due cucchiai oddio povera
che si traformerà tutto ma alla fine e
sterili ne siamo pazzi e facciamo questi
esperimenti pazzi ora il city pronti
aggiungiamo la pa vediamo se abbastanza
13 di gioco era ok ragazzi ho preso
l'acqua secondi la magia a cadere
iniziamo giorno poco per volta
guardate già come cresce
[Musica]
e devo ancora mischiarla e attenzione
perché ti ho continua a crescere un
sacco poi quando la miss chi cresce
ancora di più oggi con tantissima
mettiamo il resto della pasta straborda
non fa niente tanto ormai gruppo lire
tutto continua a crescere e dimostra i
suoi fuori da una ciotola
oddio che ma piano piano piano senza
puntare mondragon ufo la vicenda in
questo già accadendo
e poi dobbiamo pure mischiarla perché se
noi troppo dura sì lo sono orami
commenti mi scrive rete tutti i due
riprendono calcio troppo grande ma non
hanno nessuna ciotola più grande giuro
che la compro non mi aspettavo di fare
tutto questo casino comunque direi che
abbiamo gruppo di neve vendite invece di
mettere la neve dello slam andremo a
mettere lo slide neve perché questo non
è uno slide con la neve ma è una neve
con lo slime ecco qua lo slime
[Musica]
che iniziamo mescolarlo vediamo
seppelliamo lo nella neve guardate si è
già formato losno slimer normale
praticamente cosa succederà secondo voi
si formerà o no scrivete loro nei
commenti
oddio da tutto il coraggio per
continuare a inglobare la neve nel lo
slime allora finora mi sembra tutto che
un addio
forse si sta sciogliendo un po troppo ma
non vi preoccupate perché poi possiamo
aggiungere l'animatore o oddio la voce
che strano dio è diventato tipo liquido
continuiamo mescolare stranissimo si è
sciolto si è sciolta completamente vi
preoccupate ora andiamo a riattivarlo ma
aggiungiamo anche la neve gr caduta
ovviamente ecco qua però devo dire che
massaggio alle mani
massaggio un sacco le mani proprio pc
consumer o vi rilassate altro che va di
più il boom cioè che strano è diventato
tipo non lo so una pappetta una pompetta
cenette trasformato in una cosa strana
sarebbe proviamo ad aggiungere lastrico
attore riattivarlo vediamo se succede
qualcosa a se stesse ma che sta
succedendo niente assistente un po di
polvere di unicorno o penso che noi
abbiamo perso per sempre perché non
succede niente propria madre senza la
sua soluzione per le non so se devo
continuare a rischiarlo
vorrei per me però siccome rilasciate
mischiatelo ci provano comunque avete
una bolletta senza forma o non so perché
ma canino ha un bel colore no del suo
colore penso che non sia più
recuperabile purtroppo tutto il casino
che oggi o dopo dovrà pulire tutto
guarda guarda ti filamenti wow
bellissimo e perfetto
cedendo qualcosa chiamato forse si dovrà
solo staccare un pochino che si sta
ricreando lo slime mostrarlo si è
ricreato ragazzi non si posso credere ma
sono riusciti a recuperarlo praticare 88
un pezzo per volta e ho iniziato a
schiacciarlo per bene sul tavolo e
guardate un po eccolo qua il bios la mg
a credere che anche questa funzionato
prima di fare questo salto pensava
castello è stato tutto un disastro che
non sarebbe uscito nessuno slime sono
usciti tutti ora ripulisco bene tutto
così
rivediamo tutti e tre e scegliamo il
vincitore che dovrete votare nei
commenti il vincitore
allora ragazzi separata da leggere 11
leggere un vincitore
ricapitoliamo line numero uno eccolo qua
e nello slang fatto con il play che non
meritiamo
clay slime pasteur il nostro slim
complicato da scrivere
allora diciamo slime numero uno chi vota
per lo slime numero 1 come vincitore
allora di positivo a che fa delle forme
bellissime appunto come la plastilina si
può modellare come volete non è però
morbido quanto gli altri appunto perché
si possono fare le prove che vuoi
eccolo qua il numero uno come vincitore
lo scrive ora nei commenti il numero due
lo snow slime che pensavamo fosse morto
ma siamo riusciti a salvarlo incredibile
sentiamo un po di suoni si vuole trovare
me
e morbidissimo non fa moltissimi suoni
essendoci tantissima neve però è
veramente soffice ed è anche molto
grande e averci messo bellissimo da
toccare mustazza le mani fantastico chi
vota per il numero 2 come vincitore lo
scriva ora miei commenti bellissimo
13 il famoso slime nuvola sembra
veramente una nuvola è sofficissimo
perché non si ribalta no ho fatto
proprio sfiorante una patata lessa
veramente veloce del manitoba perché è
super soffice anche dei suoni un po ho
fatto alti e questo praticamente e
schiuma da barba forno slime vabbè anche
gli altri sono neve con slime è play off
line
praticamente allora chi vota per il muro
a tre come vincitore lo scrive ora miei
commenti
io chi ne leggo come vincitore il numero
uno il numero due
ho inoltre rullo di tamburi
io leggo il numero 3
la mia reazione ma adoro questo slime è
fantastico e cito gigante nonostante non
abbiano dato tanta colla e food è una
misura del paradiso è fantastico quindi
per me questa challenge la vince il
numero 3
potrei sapere voi che i commenti chi la
vince secondo voi
se questo video si disinteressa andrò a
fare un altro episodio di robbie
ingredienti nel nord live
anzi scrivetemi nei commenti quali
ingredienti volesse t e metta nello
slargo appunto in grande quantità nello
slargo bevetevi tutto nei commenti e ora
vi lascio 4 pater linee su cui potete
cliccare i miei asus live challenge
video divertenti cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione